hey belle what a guess what a guest
well the numbers are going to be high on
this one oh but you sabotaged this i
told you it was going to be a good one
and i did not get
did you hang on george did you did you
have
um talking points for per person i
purposely did the podcast this way
right so that it wouldn't do the numbers
no no no i purposely kind of held back a
little bit
i think there was still some interesting
moments in the
some great stuff bobby i had uh i think
not very much not very much should we
title this podcast
bare minimum with george kimmel that's
exactly what it is
after torch came up you know after 255
more
episodes i'll get another chance guys
for the uh for the big time i'm
waiting you can come back on when you
have a kid
well thanks for listening to another
episode of tiger belly i love you guys
so much
um we have a patreon check that out we
uh
we do vlogs we do vlogs yeah um we are
kyle and i are going to go to the desert
so if we die in the desert
god bless you but think of us we will
but we're going to the desert tomorrow
just to take a little vacay and um
i really appreciate you guys i love you
guys so much and one day
i'll maybe go on the road one day and
meet meet y'all
um but um i thank you for being with us
during this pandemic
and i appreciate it thank you so much
for listening good night and thank you
guys everybody okay good night has said
like you know i can't wait
but they should interview george he
should be in the seat i'm sorry i
disappointed you but to everybody who i
like said no that's a bad idea too
um i was right so uh shoots man
why did you not do that i'm gonna come
back in here and record one all by
myself just to for redemption what did
you want to say
i wanted to be more interesting i hear
you sit here what did you just you
didn't do it you imagine yourself if
you're on this side you have to you have
to
listen in this hot seat and you always
imagine yourself doing a lot better than
you don't think that i've ever oh i
fought over toy story you know that's
not like the sport
but you don't think that i'm gonna go
down is my history we're going to clip
the toy store
i [ __ ] crushed it i still remember
you watched it i cried
you guys arguing over ikea dishes and
dogs and like
and like an argument like outside of
like parts barbecue or something from
before like just the audio only ones
where you were yelling at each other
across the street i was like i gotta i
can find something in here in my
40 years of history that's as good as
that it's okay
no nothing your voice is cracking but
thank you for being here
um my assessment of your performance
today on the podcast
is a um a seven wow out of
100. i always get
thanks for listening guys bye-bye